ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show uh we appreciate it we're
back on Saturday nights we're all over
the place this summer uh in terms of uh
releasing
um but we're gonna remain for the
foreseeable future on Saturday evenings
um and thanks everybody for all the
messages and well wishes
uh and things that you uh sent me about
um the death of Evgeni pagosian
um who's a uh was a kind of a part of my
life and a factor
um a force in the last several months
um and I appreciate that and uh it's sad
when these things happen
because we don't we barely know
uh we we knew this man for a little bit
and I felt like there was more to come
um certainly the American Media was
saying that
they were saying that there was more to
come from him they were very excited
about uh what was happening with him and
how much uh the Russians were you know
that Putin was gonna it was he was down
bad Putin was down bad and he was really
like it was a rough people were like no
longer respecting him and this guy
pregosian he had attempted this coup it
didn't work the president of Belarus
stepped in and negotiated a deal which
seemed at the time like you know maybe
it would be a little bit of a setup uh
and but
then this guy gets blown out of the air
uh with all of his top like lieutenants
assistants all the commanders of Wagner
group you know the his private military
because what's interesting about this
guy is he's he is a warlord like he's he
started out selling hot dogs
and he then makes
inroads with Putin they're both from
Saint Petersburg and that's the thing
about Russia it's kind of like a Clash
of Clans you have people from St
Petersburg people from Moscow you know
like shogu and jerasman off and all
these other guys are from
you know wherever they're all from they
all have these they all grew up together
and they all have these certain little
Mafia units that they are a part of
and this guy and Putin were buddies from
when Putin was like a young guy Putin
was just like a dude uh in the local
government and him and uh pagosian
became Buddies and Putin kind of helped
him out
and he helped him out pagosian had spent
like nine years in jail because he like
choked a woman out stole her pocketbook
he was a rabble Rouser and he was um
you know uh incarcerated in a in a in a
no joke Real Deal Russian prison
and then came out of that
started selling hot dogs and then became
they used to call him Putin Chef Putin's
caterer
he starts catering you know there's
photos with him get the photo up of him
serving I believe it's George W bush
he was serving
yeah he's there
well he's serving Putin but I think Bush
there's there's there you go there you
go
there's pagosian isn't that fun for the
bushes or somewhere in Texas I'd be like
remember that guy that served us borscht
when we were in Moscow he tried to take
over Russia and then Putin blew his
plane
up
but what's interesting about this guy
right he looks like any sommelier you'd
see it like a New York restaurant any
Mater D Major D he was uh he is a
warlord
cutting people's heads off
but right there he's like you know he
looks like a sommelier
serving
our leader at the time gwb in the
Kremlin
he was a it's funny to have those two
sides of you to like have an
appreciation for Cuisine and yet also
end up someone who would behead people
in the street which is what you know
when they raided his uh Wagner PMC
headquarters or his house I was reading
that like he had photos of the people he
had beheaded
in in uh like in his house we had photos
of like the heads
that he had taken off it was like
Colonel Kurtz a little bit uh apocalypse
now but it started you know
you know he was a chef and Putin brought
him in he started making a lot of money
he started the Wagner PMC which was this
private military contractors this
private military group that Russia would
send to do certain things that they
needed done
Syria what not they did a lot of work in
Africa a lot of African Warlords that
are upset that this guy's dead
they're not happy because he would go
into a Wagner and he would provide
private security to African Warlords and
they would give him they would give
Russia Mining rights
and a lot of the Wagner is very um
they're very uh
you know
uh engaged and active in in on that
continent in Africa
and you know so pregosia is like he's a
cartoon character
in the sense that he was a hot dog
salesman who then became this kind of
high-end caterer he also you know
furnished meals for the Russian military
that's where he made the big money he
made a lot of money he became a
billionaire he's an oligarch but he
liked killing he liked killing people
and he was good at it and he was good at
talking and dealing with Killers rapists
murderers like even Putin get up the
Putin quote
uh after he died Putin said something
interesting Putin was like he made
mistakes in his life by the way you
gotta love the way Putin talks number
one Putin they clearly did this right
they CL his plane was clearly they put a
bomb in it or whatever and but Putin you
know the kremlins comes out and goes no
no hey this is
this is you take a chance when you fly
the kremlin's got to go no no no every
time your plane takes off you gotta say
a prayer because you just take a chance
when you fly it's not a it's a it's
weird that he tried to do a coup and
that his plane had a malfunction it's
the timing is odd but this is not us
this is not us
putting girls have known pagosian for a
long time since the early 90s
Putin describing him as a talented
businessman with a complicated fate
who made serious mistakes in his life
but what I love Putin said is he also
Putin goes he got uh the necessary
results
pregosian when he was talking about him
because he has made mistakes in his life
and he he's he got the necessary results
he did the things it needed to be done
to get where we needed to go
and the Western media
like some of them have an understanding
of Russia a lot of them don't
a lot of them don't I don't know
where they get a lot of the stuff they
get it from
I don't know if it's fed to them
directly from the CIA or if they just
you know watch movies and just think
that they'll just go well that might be
the way it happened because it you know
happened in a movie like I don't know
where they get any of this stuff like
the CNN article that I posted and people
were like well that was 10 days before
he died
it was like CNN was like pagosian is
large and apparently in charge it was a
let's get this article up it's
interesting because it shows the
disconnect
and I knew when pragosian was going to
die by the way I knew when he was
I knew when he was and and we'll
go into that
um uh and it it was a moment and it was
after that attempted coup and I said God
he's not thinking
um so CNN where in the world is Wagner
warlord pagosian at large and in charge
apparently and this article that we're
gonna get up is just basically uh it's
so it's the disconnect
is is is is very very apparent if you
like just think of how things in that
part of the world work like you don't
you don't get away it's not America you
don't get away with it like America's
still a really fun country where you can
do
you can run into the capitol with horns
on that guy's doing interviews now I
think he's he might be running for
congress the Q Anon Shaman like in
America it's still fun you could still
do things for the gram in America it's
like as long as you're willing to get
progressively crazier in America there's
genuinely a way like if Trump just said
I'm not running for president anymore
he's like I'm done I'm gonna go back to
hosting water balloon fights everybody
get their tits out I'm gonna be nasty
and rude he there would be billions of
dollars behind him to do anything he
wanted in the media space the reason
they're indicting him every other day is
because they don't want him running for
president and he's done some criminal
stuff for sure but that's why they're
indicting him if Trump had said I'm
going back to entertainment
the money would have lined up behind him
you know it didn't matter about January
6th they wouldn't care because they go
they just saw more money with that guy
we could make more money he'll do
another show he'll do another Apprentice
but this time and we'll they'll make a
fake set they would have looked like the
White House they would let him sit in a
fake Oval Office in in L.A somewhere in
Burbank in his studio and he would fire
people and he would be the fake
president and he would be nasty and rude
and it would be great and no one would
remember January 6th you know President
Bush you know Guantanamo Bay torture
Iraq Afghanistan doesn't no one cares
he's on Ellen he said look he's painting
look at the horse he painted
we forget as long as you're willing to
get progressively crazier like if you
did all that like Bush you just
have to show up on Ellen and go now I'm
a painter now I'm painting
and that level of insanity we respect
he's an artist the guy that dragged
everybody's through the war and tortured
all these people and destroyed our image
abroad is an artist now so as long as
you're willing to go crazier and crazier
you can figure it out in America it's
still why it's the greatest country in
the world
because Donald Trump would have been
fine if he just left there's no route
for pregosian to do a game show there's
zero root that's not how Russia works
that's not how it works you can't go be
the host of Wheel of Fortune after
you've tried to cool but in America you
can if Trump was like listen we got a
little people got together they got a
little wacky they got a little out you
know it's it then he would go listen I
get it it was a little nuts but but now
we're back on streaming
Amazon Netflix every single all of these
people when they had assurances he was
no longer going to be the president
when they knew he was out of political
life when they when they knew he was
done they would have opened the Vault of
money for him
Fox everybody because he's a magnet of
eyeballs
they don't want him running the country
they're for a myriad of reasons but they
want to watch or they love them the
media loves him they adore him there's
nothing can't get enough of them they
want to hear them they want them to call
people names that they hate they also
hate Ron DeSantis but they want Trump to
destroy Rhonda they want him to call Ron
to send his names but but because he is
currently still amazingly the front
runner for the presidency they you know
he's going to be indeed they just indict
him indict him indict him indictment
item and we just bury you in paper
because we're not going to blow your
plane out of the air here we're gonna
bury you in paper to prevent you
from running for president but they
don't care
about him like there was a route for him
to just go right back slide right back
and become a media uh Kingpin I think he
was interested in that before he got
elected he was interested in the Trump
TV something like that he could have
taken the whole Fox News audience it
would have been his and nobody would
have cared right just in in the same way
the the thing is when I knew pragosian
was going to die is when it went look at
this photo and by the way let's read a
little bit of this article too here
because this will make
some of my point for me it is why
America by the way is still far and wide
the best country to live in
it's the greatest country to live in
because there are there are roots to
Redemption
in this country that do not exist
anywhere else
there are roots to redemption in this
country that don't exist anywhere else
and a lot of them have to they live in
the entrepreneurial
world if Kevin Spacey comes out with a
meal plan that's good he's that kinda it
I'm telling you we will forget if he
comes out with some vitamin water type
thing
I you can do it it you can it you can
come back here
and we will suck you drive the last of
your money
but Russia's the old world America is
the new world and in the new world
perception is everything we manufacture
realities what Karl Rove said we're an
Empire when we act we manufacture
reality it is what we say it is
but in Russia it is not
in Russia it is the old world and beefs
are settled in a very old world way
like blowing your plane out of the sky
or do you get shot in the face people in
Russia you know uh leaders of opposition
parties people that have challenged uh
Putin journalists uh people they get
shot in the face there
it's an old system there's no route to
redemption in that country the way that
there is in America you cannot go host
The View
Rosie O'Donnell like you know what I
mean it's like you you have a fixed
amount of possibilities in Russia in the
old world of how it's going to work
you're going to be rich you're going to
be dead
those are the two possibilities in that
Mafia That's Mafia Mafia rules
rich or dead
it's Mafia rules in America we got oh
man we got options
we got you think you're rich you're
famous you're famous and not rich you're
both you're dead half dead you've come
back
you've got a thing going on with
uh Netflix you have a podcast you were a
mob rat now you got a podcast you're
back out with all the guys you're ratted
on the mafia everybody's on a podcast
reading ads for blue chill because it's
still the greatest country in the world
that doesn't happen over there that's
not the case if you're a rat it's over
there
because they don't have the monetization
they don't know how to make money off
people they would otherwise killed like
we do
in Russia you just gotta kill the people
that bother you just gotta kill them
in America you can kind of let them
around
late last week imprisoned Russian
opposition leader Alexi navalny was
handed a harsh judgment
after a court hit him with a 19-year
sentence in a penal colony he was sent
immediately to a punishment cell
it was a stark contrast to the fate of
you getting pregosian against the person
who's writing this isn't aware that
they're talking about Russia they think
they're talking about America and the
reason that I knew he was in trouble get
the photo up of the guy taking the
selfie with him when he was leaving
Russia look at this
they're doing it for the gram he doesn't
get it pregosian doesn't get it he
signed his death Lauren when he did that
little March that he was doing at
rastavandan and then on the way to
Moscow he fired on military helicopters
and killed Russian servicemen he can't
not be killed Putin would have no
credibility he was always going to be
killed every dummy in the Press Corps
over here from the Atlantic to New York
Times like well no this is interesting
Putin's uh it's the real like uh you
know pretty embarrassing that this
happened and this guy's running around
it's like no he's not going to be killed
the next day
but this was pretty soon this was pretty
good and I saw that photo I said
he's dead he's dead he's dead
people are taking selfies with him he
thinks he's in America he thinks he's an
American he thinks he's going to get an
agent
s look at the pictures of him smiling
with the people he thinks CAA is gonna
sign him he thinks there's another way
out because the internet's powerful and
I'm sure the CIA and all these people
are giving him feeding him all kinds of
crap like no no you come over here and
we'll look the other way you know you
know there's probably something for you
to do you know he once very much he
likes Fame he's kind of delighting in it
there's a guy that was cutting heads off
he was a warlord to get the other photo
where he's like yeah there he is he's
happy he's bullied this was a guy who
was a few uh 48 hours before this photo
he was trying to overthrow the
government of Russia which didn't work
because people in Russia go no no no no
or is the mafia we're all getting paid
we're it's like we're we're in the it's
a We're In Cahoots here we're in cahoots
and said it's a whole what are you doing
he's like the people have been lied to
and everyone's going yeah we know we're
not we're lying to that what are you
what do you think you're gonna come in
when you think you're you're gonna come
in here on some like white knight White
Horse Ride in tell everybody and they
know he's a warlord it's a corrupt
warlord cutting heads off
this isn't Thomas Jefferson and I know
Thomas Jefferson wasn't Thomas Jefferson
don't bother me with that but my point
is that they all know this guy they know
him
did the warlord is cutting people's
heads off it's gonna come in and no
they're all being they're enriched by
the Putin regime
and they're going dude he thinks he's
gonna get support from all these guys
because some of them probably don't like
the Ukraine Wars some of them are like
it's our money up but they know
that the reality is
they've got all their money with Putin
they've got all their eggs in that
basket so he finds out
they're not coming over to him
he's not gonna go whack the Don in front
of everybody it's not gonna work
so then he's like
oh
he goes well we're not okay sorry
I made my point he did this thing he did
this like a bad face where he goes hey
I made my point I you know I killed a
few Russian servicemen by the way that's
not forgivable none of it's forgivable
to Putin right it's not really so he
then reverses course and the the leader
of Belarus goes he'll come to Belarus
and then I saw these photos and he's
leaving and he's doing the celebrity
thing or maybe that's when he arrived in
Belarus I don't know but he's taking
selfies with people and he's smiling and
he's happy and I'm going
he doesn't understand
his fate or if he does he did a great
job disguising it
but I think he got a little in his
feelings as people would say and he
started to believe his own myth and he
started thinking like I just
smacked one of the most powerful men in
the world in the face and he did nothing
and now everybody's taking selfish with
me everybody loves me I'm fine I'm back
I'm in
but unlike America you can't go host
Miss Universe again which Donald could
have
and I'm not saying they're I'm not
equating them I'm just saying in terms
of the paths to Redemption there aren't
any in Russia you it you just live and
die
by what you did not so much what you can
do
so pagosian takes all these photos and
here's this article that shows kind of
the misunderstanding of that it was a
stark contrary to the fate of hug any
progression the head of the Russian
Mercury group Wagner back in June
pagosian led the abortive Mutiny that
presented the biggest challenge to
Russian Vladimir Putin in over two
decades of rule while pregosian's troops
stopped short of Moscow
a furious Putin said in a televised
speech that those on the quote path of
treason would face punishment almost two
months later in the case of the Wagner
Chief this simply hasn't happened
and then they did Cover themselves they
go clearly the price for confronting
Putin is not fixed perhaps more
surprisingly Goshen hasn't even kept a
low profile since the tune up or I think
what was weird is that this guy didn't
just disappear
okay
he didn't just disappear he came back
to Russia and he's like taking photos
with people
you know it's crazy you gotta just he
should have just went to Africa they
still would have killed him they still
would have killed him
but he might have bought himself a
little time if he went to Africa like
he's in Russia
it's crazy
while subscribers to his telegram
telegram Channel have become accustomed
to seeing him in camouflage in tactical
gear pagosian was spotted in a polo
shirt and mom jeans cutting a seemingly
more mild manner figure Than A month's
Pat yeah he's Gotta Die
are you nuts
he got like really famous for that and
now he's losing his mind he's doing good
Glam shots in St Petersburg in a in a
polo shirt like I'm a famous guy now on
the world stage
sorry I tried to overthrow the
government but listen
there's got to be equity in my brand no
isn't there equity in this brand
it's it's old rules there and I knew he
was gonna get I didn't know how he was
gonna get it
but I knew he was gonna get it was no
question but all these articles that
were coming out in the American Press
which I understand they're just writing
articles to try to you know piss Putin
off and whatever make it seem like he's
good has no control over the country and
again I'm not I'm not like Bros with
Vladimir but one must say that now
because people can't listen with the
critical thought it's no longer a
faculty that most people in this country
possess
um somebody tried to debate this with me
on Instagram and I never respond but I
started responding with voice memos to
someone and then eventually they were
just like well I don't really have all
the fat it's like no one has all the
facts but this this idea that you have
to come out and tell people you know
you're not uh you don't adore
Vladimir Putin to just call a spade a
spade and say up is up and down is most
likely down and I knew that this guy
probably wasn't get away with it so let
us fast forward but again you could see
how out of his mind he is in the polo
shirt look at this photo he's out of his
mind
he was he was a week away from going
back to being a chef that's how crazy he
went he was on a level of crazy where he
was going to start food blogging soon
like he was gonna be start he would he's
trying to get on Chopped like he was
trying to go backwards to when he was
the chef he was like nonetheless forget
about the clue forget about you I lobbed
a few heads off bygones everyone does I
shot a few a rushed in the planes out of
the air not a big deal let's go back to
my real passion food let's go back to my
real passion like there's you know in
his crazy head I know in his crazy head
because I met a lot of people that are
really famous not like my level of fan
which is like who cares I'm talking
about people that are genuinely like
they pop to get really really famous and
it is an interesting thing that happens
in your head
where the possibilities seem endless
because the people that are employed to
work with you their job is to make the
possibilities seem endless so once
you've gotten some level of Fame people
they sit around you in Office Buildings
in Los Angeles and go you know you you
know you could you could do the Olympics
have you trained at all for the Olympics
no I know you're 40 and fat but there's
got to be what about curling there's got
to be an event that you could get in and
even if you don't Place top three it's
such great there's so many eyeballs
there'll be so many eyeballs on you
doing the Olympic like their job is not
to live in reality their job is to make
you feel like anything you ever wanted
to do not only is possible but it's a
good idea it's a great idea
you want to make a song having never
sang and have never had any musical to
do it
do it Studio's ready you will be in the
studio tomorrow Taylor Swift if she
wants to act she can act she can do
anything she wants no one will tell if
Taylor Swift wanted to go in into Russia
and do what Wagner did there would be
people going you know I think we can do
it I think we can do because no one will
tell her no she is the most powerful
person on in this country right now
because she's made a billion dollars and
when you make a billion dollars in the
summer
I can't even get people in Charlotte
Charlotte North Carolina don't me
I've said horrible things about you and
I'll continue to but buy the tickets
don't start September what 15th my point
is Taylor Swift's made a billion when
you make a billion dollars in a summer
the person who tells you no will be
thrown out of a window they will you
will never hear the word no anything she
wants to do if she wants to like perform
on a on if she wants to take a 747 up
there I do like concert in the sky and
parachute like no one will tell her no
because she made a billion dollars on a
tour in the summer this is this is you
know when you get that big when you're
that big and pregosian did the Russian
version of that he tried to take over
Moscow he tried to beat the Kremlin that
is the difference of the two countries
in America our biggest star is Taylor
Swift in Russia it was evgeny pagosian
because he tried to topple the Kremlin
and nothing gets more press in Russia
than a war sure they have pop stars they
have people that try to do it they come
back
come on and they're all you know they're
drunk and they're in a club and it works
you know everybody's trying to get laid
and you can listen to that crap for a
while you know
but they don't do what we do they do War
they do Coos so pagosian's the guy like
damn
but our Goshen is is the person who made
a billion dollars selling white girl
nostalgia in the summer Taylor Swift God
love her
again that people say to me why don't
you like her no no she's great I just
again I wasn't around I was doing Coco
selling mortgage it wasn't for me it
wasn't for me
what happened to Kim SWAT get up Kim
swazi remember that song she was a Kim
swazi and you know what is she doing now
bartending when I was doing coke in
clubs in Long Island
they would play people like Kim swazi
s-u-o-z-z-i and she had like two songs
which is all any entertainer of her
caliber should ever have and and one of
them was pretty good
I forgot which one it was the Alone song
I don't know where this woman is she's
probably in Russia but she
she did the song Alone play along play
the video could we play the video are we
gonna get clipped uh I'd just have to
file a copyright yeah ah it's not worth
it
my point is that I was listening to this
idiot
doing coke and uh yeah right This
Woman's serving lobster rolls right now
montauks they're probably broke my point
is that I missed Taylor Swift not that
she's not good it's you know it is what
it is but my point is that when
pragosian thought he was Taylor Swift
I knew he was gonna be dead
that's the whole game I've always said
that people uh that are losing their
hair should fight it like a war
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are 35 more than 50 million men in the
U.S suffer from male pattern baldness
Noah snap I hear is fully bald but he's
got a wig I'm kidding I kid him
uh keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors because you know
here's the deal with keeps I don't know
if you know what it is
um but it is a expert recommended hair
loss treatment it's a personalized
treatment plan that's recommended by
licensed medical provider and delivered
straight to your door
with keeps you get quality expert care
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or Pharmacy easily subscribe to keeps
and you'll get refill reminders you'll
never have to run low
keeps us a network of medical advisors
prescribers Care Specialists to support
you each treatment comes with a full
year of unlimited messaging so you can
connect with your people anytime you
want low cost treatment plans are
affordable they're typically half the
cost of a pharmacy prices whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care
of the hair you have keeps as you
covered remember prevention is key
treatments take 46 months to see results
so act fast if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
keps.com Tim Dillon receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-p-s.com Tim Dillon to get your first
month of treatment for free
k-e-e-p-s.com Kim Dillon d-i-l-l-o-n I
was so stressed out trying to get Taylor
Swift tickets that I couldn't even I had
a panic attack I was laying on the floor
all my girlfriends I was calling them
I'm like like what the f you
know
and it was hard and I you know because
it's it was it was the soundtrack of our
lives at summer camp and I was like you
um you know and so what happened was it
was so tough but now I use game time
that's what I use Game Time right it's a
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
sorts of sports music comedy theater
near you killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over the tickets
and start getting hyped for the full the
fun you'll have because that's what you
I was thinking about like what am I
wearing what are we all gonna wear when
she does my favorite one that she does
is um
is ostrich
it's like the craziest most beautiful
song
that I remember and it's beautiful for
my childhood it's she's like you got a
long neck
I cannot stretch it's so good Taylor
Swift song ostrich got a long neck like
an ostrich
he's got a long neck like an ostrich
it's swoof boy it's powerful it's
powerful
um so go to game time and get the app
don't around here folks start doing
this download the game time app create
an account use code Tim for twenty
percent of your first purchase Tim 20 of
your first purchase because you don't
have to you can just it's easy you get
the tickets it's easy it's not fight you
know there's so much fighting now with
the family
um you could just go and hear
um
Taylor Swift do a lot of her material
um because that's where I I was trying
to get tickets to Taylor Swift and I
couldn't because they were sold out I
started crying
and it was bad
I just wanted to hear her do
there's a song she does that I really
really like
um
[Music]
I forget the name of it
it's see here's here's my conundrum
right now I'm gonna tell the audience
whatever I say now he's gonna get taken
out of the ad it would be very very
funny but whatever I say like whatever
song I say is going to get removed so
just in your head think of something I
would have said that would have been
funny because you would never have heard
it anyway because this has happened
before and we just have to take it out
but what what is real
is the game time app create an account
use Tim for 20 off your first purchase
download game time today last minute
tickets low prices guaranteed now let's
talk about his death because it is
and now they're Atlantic still doing it
if any progression may have the last
laugh they won't stop they won't stop
these people at the Atlantic no no no
he's still won
remember and by the way haven't they
said Putin's been dying for like seven
years they've said he said inoperable
incurable everything for years and years
and years and he's still you see him
he's fine
I think he's got doubles too Putin where
he's got there's a lot of Putin's in
Russia that look like him so they go out
and it's kind of interesting again
we can learn from him a little bit can
we say that obviously he's done some
wrong things
many wrong things but it is an
interesting way to compare the two kind
this is a perfect way to look at the two
countries
there is no way that you can't know the
selfie Squad ends
the Selfies end
so what happened what happened do we he
got in his plane do we have anything can
we get a maybe a Kremlin spokesperson to
deny this I don't think we because
they're all speaking Russian it doesn't
matter anyway but the Kremlin said this
has nothing to do with us and then
people came out and go this is
unprofessional Putin wouldn't be
involved in this I think Luka Shango
Belarus he's the president of Belarus
came out and was like hey uh Because by
the way never make a deal with that guy
huh but
he told them to watch out lukashenko I
read he told him he goes listen guys
watch out but
you know he came out and he had to say
because he has to say he has to go hey
this you know this isn't Putin's work
this is unprofessional well it seems
pretty professional to me it seems
pretty pretty good
but lukashenko has to come out and go no
no no no
um it's actually it's
um it's it's not what it seems we don't
know who did it a lot of people are mad
at him a lot of people were angry
nothing really happens in Russia kind of
without Putin's say so at that level
right yeah
um so now people are saying explosion
likely brought down aircraft purportedly
carrying Wagner boss flight data and
video uh analysis there is a puff of
white and then a plane can be seen
failing
falling
a trail of smoke or vapor stretching
behind it descending rapidly against a
bright blue sky the person
filming the video zooms is as the
aircraft spirals downwards out of
control revealing that it's missing a
wing
wow
you know you think at the end he knew
when the bomb would not he knew there
was a split stick there's always a few
seconds to know there's always a few
seconds to go you know
as the end of the machine story where
Bert Kreischer go with the guy says the
bird Crusher because this is Russia you
know like I wonder if that's what evgeny
pagosian thought as soon as that bombing
off like oh this is Russia so there is
the plan I don't know if you guys can
see it it's
hard to see but it is coming down
at an altitude I mean it's coming down
very quickly and this is what happens
you know obviously if an explosion blows
the wing off
it's over it's over a lot a plane can
handle a lot a lot of turbulence a lot
of different things but when you blow
the wing off
it's done and you can see it just falls
to the ground and here's the other thing
get up who was on that plane because man
did they take everybody out they took
everybody out at once and there's
reported now I don't know if this is
true or not the percussion may have been
on his way to see Putin
in Saint Petersburg she was taking off
from Moscow
um the people in this plane were all
high level members of Wagner they took
everybody out this was a mob hit where
they killed an entire family they went
in and they whacked an entire family so
you've got pregosian obviously Dimitri
utkin
okay he's one of you evgeny pagosian's
top Associates as well as a reputed
operational leader of the Wagner
mercenary group done
um
Valerie eganovic check it off
she's a
he's a businessman who holds senior
positions in pagosian's Empire done
divinity maracan
um he was affiliated with Wagner they
don't know that much about him Sergey
prabhutsin
fought in the second Chechen Warren
joined Wagner in March 2005. Nikolai met
suzev
um
they didn't know what his deal is
Alexander tottman these are all the
people in the Manifest the other
non-crew passages on the flight is
Alexander totman
whose call sign is taught
um the center did not publish additional
information about an apparent Wagner uh
member and then sadly the crew members
for the flight
um which by the way I I mean can you
imagine that getting that flight you'd
go hey uh
can I can I like fly a plane without an
engine instead of this because it would
be imagine seeing that guy imagine
you're a flight attendant in Moscow and
you walk into work and you get your
vodka and you pour it in the coffee or
whatever they're doing
you get on you put your lipstick on get
the tits where they should be I mean
it's still a it's still a country where
I believe the flight attendants have to
you know I think they have to this is my
guess
you know not here where it's I mean
Christ right I mean
I mean the things that stalk the Isles
of planes in this country the half-dead
army of mutants that's that just up and
down the aisles
oh
um but you walk in and you like look at
it everybody and then you're like
the guy who tried to overthrow the
government is on the plane this morning
and then you hear the
explosion and it's over and then it's
over quickly and it'll be it'll be
forgotten quickly and they'll move on
and this is what Russia does
this is the inevitable and only way that
it can be resolved over there there
isn't this was the whole point of my
kind of rant about it is just that it is
why we're clearly the better country in
the more fun country
you know because you've got any pagosian
cooking show would be more fun that
would be fun to see him like try to be
like a person after he just lobbed heads
off and he's like the the consistency of
the soup is too thick
um but you could tell that's where he
was going in his own mind he lived a
very interesting life and rip to him
and my the sad thing is him and my
mother would have gotten along big time
they had the same ideas about Africa by
the way but no they uh they would have
they would have clearly probably gotten
along
um which is sad uh but that it was such
an interesting thing and it crystallized
to me almost a difference not not
necessarily between the old world and
the new world there's a lot of things
going on in Russia there's autocracy is
what I'm not an idiot but what I'm
saying is that it is such a very
interesting thing
um
looking at
how obvious it was to most people that
have even a rudimentary understanding of
that culture that his death warrant had
been signed
by his actions but a lot of people in
the American Media for whatever reason
were incapable of seeing that perhaps
mistaking Russia for this country where
there may have been a path to Redemption
for him as it would have been for Donald
Trump if Donald Trump was just like
let's just go back to the drawing board
let's go back to what works
I'm gonna be entertaining I'm gonna call
people I'm gonna call women fat and ugly
which no one can do anymore but it needs
to be done I'm gonna do it
and I'm going to have an Empire of
entertainment because that's all you
know
that's all fine in terms of like he
would have been allowed there would have
been
it would have been like great he would
have been welcomed back immediately he
would have been kind of welcome back in
Hollywood it would have taken maybe a
year
maybe because that town
they couldn't have less of of a fixed
idea of anything in that town it's uh
everything and everybody
for the most part
is malleable they are uh you know
um they're liquid they take the shape of
the container they are you know
incredibly uh easy to influence uh and I
think within a year you would have seen
Trump kind of climb back on the throne
of being an Entertainer if he lived five
years he'd be hosting
some big thing and it would be all okay
and he would do jokes about January 6
and people that think I'm kidding I'm
telling you you do I don't know are you
new have you lived here if he was able
to live
and he was able to stay funny and you
know he didn't get Dementia or something
he was still like George Burns like
those old guys that live forever but
they're still sharp Don Rickles people
like that if Trump still had it
in a few years
there's no way that you would not have
been welcomed back into The Fray of
the entertainment business
where they're very comfortable with him
they're not comfortable with him in the
White House
um so that's why they're indicting I
mean he's been indicted like I wake up
he's indicted I have breakfast after the
breakfast burrito in a low-carb wrap
he's indicted he's indicted multiple
times a day
how many times is four four yeah four
but to count there's so many counts
maybe she's been indicted only four
times which is a lot but there's counts
upon count I mean it's like they want
him bad now because they want they don't
want him running for president which is
why I wonder if in hindsight now he's
like I wonder if now it's too late
but I feel like now he might be going
like let me just do a show let me just
do a shot let me do wish I could do a
good show
Netflix should get him out
Fox should bail him out of jail and go
we will make sure he doesn't run for
president
build a fake White House in L.A it's no
president doesn't have a lot of power
anyway it's not a big deal build a fake
White House in a studio in Burbank let
him think he's the president let him do
pray he'll have more power than the
actual president probably let him sit
there and and on people make fun of
them
say what he wants to say he just doesn't
have the nuclear football
he can do all of that that would have
been a happy medium
but that's not percussion that's not
going to happen you're not going to go
back to being a chef you're not going to
go back
uh you know you're not going to be
embraced after a few years with
paintings got an artist now he's not
going to go on a Russian talk show in
five years ago I mean oh I'm actually an
artist now take a look see what I did
here with the oil on the canvas take a
look at that I'm also doing mixed media
now which means I incorporate see a lot
of these are old news clippings and I
fashioned through the that's not it that
is not it that is not the way it works
over there it is a cold culture of of uh
you know
final judgments over there that are
harsh that are doled out by the Kremlin
and you get shot in the face or your
plane blows up or you get poisoned you
do not get a TV show you do not pass go
you do not collect 200 you do not get
the Russian version of chopped you don't
go on Allen and bring the yard out and
talk about how you're sorry about
torturing everybody into Wars but here
take a look at the art you're really
into that you know you've been painting
a lot you're not allowed to do any of
that
doesn't work it's not O.J Simpson where
you can come out and be after killing
your wife somehow the most rational guy
on Twitter and like genuinely a steward
of this country now and the things he's
saying have genuine weight and value and
we should listen to them and we should
find Common Ground politically and every
time I see him in that golf cart I am
like wow I forget that he killed his
wife and decapitated a friend
and there it's just not he had one shot
at redemption in Russian it wasn't
really Redemption he got out of jail and
then he realized pretty quickly oh I'm
committing the wrong crimes
I should be committing better crimes
that make me more money and I gotta do
that with the government
I can't commit crimes where the
government is coming to get me I have to
commit crimes with the government I'm
broadcasting from New York today uh a
couple of buildings next to me Goldman
Sachs had the same realization they had
the same realization what we can't how
many women can we choke and grab the
pearls
and then as the government's trying to
get us we got to work with the
government we got to commit crimes with
the government so it wasn't really a
Redemption Arc it was a shift in
strategy
it was a shift in strategy and he said
well I cook these hot dogs I make good
hot dogs
and then he said let's do that and then
the government said here's what we're
gonna do
you're going to provide all the food
you're going to be the chef
and then he goes okay and then he
started the Wagner PMC and he goes let's
start doing this and then he started the
internet research agency he evolved Tick
Tock Clips he did it he he did internet
research agency because like any
uh person who's you know trying to have
a good career you have to evolve
and he evolved into he goes we need a
troll Farm
and he started the internet research
agency he was indicted by the way in
America I don't I think it was indicted
for his work uh supposedly you know and
I'm sure he did with the election
over there you know by I don't know
spreading by giving my aunt rubles to
post what she would have anyway on
Facebook
but
all the election interference stuff that
we heard about at nauseum to no end was
him which was why I found it slightly
funny that when he was marching on
Moscow there were it we were gleeful
here there was Glee and people were
going Putin's hours are numbered not
even his days his hours this guy's gonna
take over we go oh who's this guy you go
oh the guy that supposedly uh destroyed
American democracy so it was that's why
I was going uh
doesn't make much sense but he met the
Fate that anybody who's paid attention
I've read books about Russia uh it's an
interesting culture it's a fascinating
culture and a hashan said that I'm
spiritually Russian because the shape of
my body and that I do like luxury
um and that I do relate to a lot of the
oligarchs and it's not by the way it's
not they've done wrong things but when
they were taking all their boats I
didn't think that was right and I went
on the record with that I didn't think
it was right and a lot of these
oligarchs are larger men and they're on
their Yachts they have their Furs and
their and I thought it was wrong
and spiritually there's something
Russian about me I don't know that's
what she said I didn't say it she said
it but uh Shia was born there I don't
listen when women speak but something
about that now although I will with
Barry Wise can you imagine this
so Barry Weiss
uh writer cultural critic journalist
um
uh Barry Weiss
called me and goes I want you to
moderate a dis or not moderate I want
you to open a discussion Elon and
Zuckerberg are gonna they're gonna have
a big debate and it's gonna be the
biggest media event in the world would
you do comedy before it and comment on
it and I said absolutely
one thousand percent
well then she called me back and
apparently a Funny Thing Happened on the
Way to the Forum because the lineup had
changed
instead of Elon we got crimes
and instead of Zuckerberg we got and a
hush and from the Red Scare podcast now
these women are lovely women
but it was slightly different in terms
of uh media
event potential perhaps
Louise Perry's on the swell as Sarah
hater I don't know these people I don't
care
now it's the theater at Ace Hotel
downtown L.A I'll be there I'll be doing
20 minutes of comedy and
some comment I'm gonna comment on this
um I can just imagine the Mossad going
this is what we're paying her to do this
is what we're paying Barry Weiss to do
we're paying her to set up
uh you know how's the sexual Revolution
failed I'll answer that yes because I'm
there it's for women speaking and I'm
showing up but she's paying fairly and
we respect her and I'm just saying with
the Russian oligarchs I'm not saying
that I'm just saying hey
let's all
be nice
is that nice NATO
to take someone's jet when they've done
nothing but sell fertilizer
they didn't invade Ukraine
they're just selling for of course they
killed a few people here and there but
they're just selling uh fertilizer
and their boat's gone so that's why I
initially
you know
like there's that Richmond north of
Richmond song where that guy's you know
it's a good song he's talking about all
the rich people to try to take
everybody's lives and livelihoods and
control everybody we can't play we'll
get in trouble but this guy respect to
this guy
um he turned out a big record deal he's
like I ain't not no different than
nobody and he's making killer money
anyway God bless him you should stay
independent it would be hilarious if in
six months he's like I'm fighting Jake
Paul I thought he just becomes a regular
content creator he's like Jake Paul get
in the ring
um but yeah it's a song everyone's like
debating the political implications of
it it's a song dummies it will do
nothing it is a nice song people should
have music
um but I want to do a Richmond north of
Richmond for the oligarchs of Russia I
want to record a song on a boat singing
about the pain it is
to be an oligarch who they take your
yacht
I wanted to talk about this article but
that's Eve getting progression I want to
talk about this the Wall Street journals
now uh telling people you know they they
always do this you know Bloomberg uh
does this CNB they all do this and it
was that famous article uh a while ago
uh you'll own nothing and you'll like it
and now there's this article drudge ran
it a while ago where they're basically
just saying to you they're going listen
we know you have an idea of what a house
is
we know you have like an idea of what it
is but you gotta get rid of that
and the title of the article I'm not I'm
not um kidding okay and again all of
these articles by the way are meant to
be written so that you will accept
lower and lower standards of living and
think they're hip
that's the game the game is that you
have to think it's cool like the title
of this article is goodbye bathtub in
living room America's homes are
shrinking faced with high mortgage rates
cost-constrained Americans are embracing
smaller homes it's hip it's cool that's
the angle
eating bugs is fun it's hip it's cool
you don't want to be an old
Boomer with a house in a yard do you
this is the game the game is to make the
lower standards of living cool see that
you feel hip and young and you feel like
it's oh it's the Zeitgeist to not have a
kitchen
isn't that the title go up it says what
does it say goes goodbye bathtub in
living room
hello prison cell goodbye bathtub in
living room America's homes are
shrinking
like Americans are and by the way
they're embracing look at the word you
they're embracing smaller Embraces what
you do when you love someone you hug
them
they're not settling now an honest
article would be goodbye bathtub in
living room America's homes are
shrinking Americans are settling
for smaller homes but they don't want
that they go Americans are embracing
smaller homes they like it it's good
it's nice when people come over your
house to everyone stands in a hallway
and talks it's nice why do you need a
living room let's read this uh article
when I when I when I see an article like
this I send it to like 20 people it
always makes me laugh
for many Americans homeownership may be
attainable only if they give up a dining
room
home prices on your record highs
frustrating millions of potential buyers
who feel priced out of the housing
market home builders are having to find
ways to make their product more
affordable to them to increase their
pool of customers
shrinking the size of a new
single-family home is increasingly
popular way to do it
smaller homes can help cause constrained
buyers face High facing High mortgage
rates they also boost the bottom line
for building
and here we are they also boost the
bottom line for Builders who are
contending with spiraling labor and
construction costs now by the way the
people building these homes it's not
like Mom and Pop Two Italian Guys who
are like building the home like hey it's
Rocco is building a home these
are
um these are massive
uh companies that build these homes
right they're private Equity companies
own all these home builders right what's
that big home builder dhdl yeah there's
K K and B what's the other one it's all
over North Carolina DH something DH
Horton or something home build it like
yeah yeah DR Horton America's largest
home builder so what these are corporate
structures
so when we talk about home builders like
people think it's like hey I got a
little juice in the deal for my baby
Giuseppe we're building your home we
need to make a little money we need to
make a little scratch how's my wife Anna
Maria gonna have um enough money for the
cheese that's not what this is right
this is Corporate
massive companies
going we need to find a way to make even
more money
so no dining room no living room it's
not independent home sizes are shrinking
the most in some of the hotter markets
the Seattle area where the size of a
newly built home is 18 smaller than it
was five years ago tops the list new
homes in Charlotte North Carolina and
San Antonio shrank by 14 percent
most Builders and Architects follow the
same basic Playbook to produce tighter
more efficient Living Spaces they're
axing dining areas bathtubs and separate
living rooms secondary bedrooms and Loft
spaces are shrinking and sometimes
disappearing you all sleep in the same
bed and each other
at the same time they're increasing the
size of multi-use rooms like kitchens
and great rooms shared spaces like bunk
rooms jacket chilled bathrooms which are
the worst things ever it's like one door
you're like in the bathroom and then the
doors opening and you're like no
um
in in some cases the kitchen island has
become the only eating area in the home
which is great it's lovely to have a
holiday to kitchen island there's
nothing better than a Thanksgiving
dinner at a kitchen island
but if we're a Godless country and
nobody even celebrates the hotties but
let's say we do occasionally right we
like Thanksgiving that's the one with
food
um and there's nothing better than
sitting in a kitchen island
uh eating Thanksgiving dinner
sitting uh parallel to your family not
looking at anyone in the eye not having
a look at them which is great because
everyone's you know everybody's on 15
anti-anxiety medications and everybody's
like you know a somewhere on a spectrum
so nobody can make eye contact so this
is nice you just sit on the kitchen
island for Thanksgiving and you stare at
the stove and if someone asks you a
question you don't even have to Crane
your head to look at them you just stare
at the stuff school is good
climate change
um
Estridge homes a semi-custom new home
builder that operates near Indianapolis
recently launched a new neighborhood
concept with detached homes 300 to 500
square feet smaller and 50 to 75 000
cheaper than it typically builds now
listen America has crazy big homes we
don't need the biggest homes in the
world right we have these massive
mcmansions rooms and rooms and rooms
that people don't use right I I
understand that there's a lot to
criticize with that you know
um but what they are saying is that God
forbid any of the corporate parent
companies and all these home builders
lose a dollar they're just gonna
convince people that having a room to
eat in for a holiday is a luxury that's
a luxury having a living room is a
luxury uh and we're you know basically
it's like
you know the room at the prison did
everyone eat sin let's do that every
house will be designed to look like a
big of a penal colony big Prison Room
where you could just sit on the floor
and eat and if you want to do it if you
want to sit at a table you do it in a
kitchen
that's great so they're gonna convince
people that a dining room is electric
they don't want to lose any money really
they don't want to lose any money they
want these big margins and the people
that run those companies have a lot of
money it's not independent mom
and pop contractors this is massive
corporate big home builders big
landlords
Blackstone places like this should own
all the houses
these are the people making these
decisions it's not like this is not like
we're getting European by the way at
good good I wonder who owns DH Horton
how big their home is right it's like
it's not about like being more
environmentally conscious and
sustainability it's not about going we
don't need 6 000 square feet it's about
convincing Americans that a living room
or a dining room is a luxury that they
do not need
because uh the people that are
billionaires need uh more billions and
billions and billions of dollars
where is this guy's house there's no way
you're gonna find his house it would be
interesting uh here we go CEO rating
he'll comparably
you're not gonna find the CEO DH
Horton's house
I guarantee it's not small
I'm gonna bet you that the CEO of DH
Horton has a dining room
David old old
you want to take that bet that he has a
living room and a dining room
soon they're gonna go multiple bathrooms
are being eliminated you have one indoor
bathroom and then you have an outdoor
bed they will go back to outhouses we'll
say that's cool actually it's very it's
good for your back to sit in the
Outhouse it's actually better for your
digestive tract to use the bathroom
outside
that's the direction that we're going to
go in and it's all because people don't
want to shrink any of them more I just
love the idea that it's a living room
and a dining room but they're not saying
limit to bedrooms they're like no we
don't no no no no no dining room
no dining room
how where are you gonna come out as
trans to your family at the kitchen
island that doesn't make any sense
Mom and Dad I think I'm a girl at the
kitchen island you're not even gonna
give a kid a dining room to other folks
they're non-binary did their gender
fluid they're gonna have to do in the
kitchen like an animal does that
make any sense
to anybody
it doesn't make any sense to me
poor you've got any pregosian
poor guy thought he was he thought he
was Taylor Swift
that guy thought he was Taylor
Swift another article in the journal
they want people to be older they want
people to live longer in this crazy
country how we age now scientists are
working to turn back the clock could
there be anything worse than trying to
keep people on this planet longer is
there a worse idea
the government later in life that's not
a young man's move later in life that's
when Trump got elected like later in
life when it gets fun that's when you go
wild
later in life you go who cares shoot for
the moon who gives a I'm not gonna
be around that much longer
so that is when you get people gotta
check out
when people get to that point where they
go I don't have to live with the
consequences of this that's when they
gotta go
that's not when we shouldn't be trying
to make people into 110 year olds here
because at 95 they're gonna go maybe
Hitler was right
it's what happens
they call this road map the Hallmarks of
Aging a set of biological features and
mechanism linked to our inexorable March
towards death over the past decade
decade the Hallmarks have helped guide
the development of drugs that clear away
cells have stopped the fighting and Gene
therapies that appear to restore cells
to a more youthful state
I'm all against this by the way this
endless prolonged life
is such a bad idea in this country
this country we're going to have people
in their 90s who are youthful and fit
and ready to start problems we're going
to be putting 90 year olds in jail for
bar fights
I mean I it's just no could there be a
worse idea than having 100 year old
people with this spring in their step
do you see these 40 56 year old Boomers
walking around Vegas you want to see
what that looks like 40 years down the
line if they're still healthy
can you imagine that the only thing that
stops people in this country's death
it's the only thing that gets even close
to stopping them
otherwise it's just forget it
I'm 97 and I'm here and I can you
imagine the level of entitlement these
Boomers would have in a hundred I've
been on this earth 100 years and you're
telling me this table's not ready yet
a hundred years these people are gonna
live the boomers are the worst
generation on Earth
we're gonna keep them here
we're gonna keep them here they're
already behaving erratically
you know the idea that we're gonna keep
them here for years and years and years
so that they could turn around and go I
have 90 years of experience
and they could be out and complaining is
the craziest thing
that I have ever seen it's insane
Taylor Swift can stay give her all the
anti-aging stuff get to get the Boomers
out of here Tim dilloncomedy.com for all
of the dates I'm in Philly it's 30
minutes outside of Philly who cares do
drugs get in the car
September 8th and 9th uh Los Angeles to
Barry Weiss crap on the 13th Charlotte
North Carolina on the 15th buy tickets
to that North Carolina I know I've said
bad things about you Lexington Kentucky
Cincinnati Ohio Davenport Iowa Des
Moines Iowa Omaha Nebraska Wheatland
Wheatland California it's really
Sacramento
um and then I'm in Australia Perth
Adelaide Sydney Brisbane Melbourne going
to New Zealand Auckland Christ Church
Rogers to New York New York New York
Carnegie Hall
amazing stand up and then a podcast with
Ray comp
uh we're doing Pittsburgh the day after
that I'm doing that Detroit
um and Toronto in December thank you
everybody subscribe uh to the podcast
share it with your friends if you want
we're on patreon every week in addition
to YouTube
um what do we it's a weird time because
my mother died and pregosian died it's
very weird it's very interesting
to to to kind of it's uh you think about
life and I and I
and I think his ultimate flaw is going I
am Taylor Swift and in Russia there is
no Taylor Swift sir
you will swiftly be dealt a blow no he
you could see it you could see the joy
in him you could see his brush with Fame
you could see he thought it was America
he thought he was Taylor Swift he
thought he was going to go on the era's
tour
but he did not it's Russia baby
it's a different game and uh you know
and he knew it the minute that bomb went
off this is a guy who's lived and died
by the sword
there was a moment of respect because he
the you know some of the biggest resets
you have in your life for in a minute in
a moment right David Carr was a media
columnist for the Times wrote a book
called The Night of the gun and it was
about it we was smoking crack and he
looked at his children in the car and he
said I was prepared to be a bad person
but I was not prepared to be a bad
father so on a dime because I got to get
help I got to change my life there are
all kinds of instances where people
change your life on a dime they have
this white light moment you know and
so sometimes you could get a reset and
sometimes it'll happen
instantaneously
where you know the the the the Chariot
or whatever it is becomes a pumpkin Snow
White it's like this that's Snow White
Cinderella the stroka midnight
everything goes back to the way it was
you know the stroke of midnight we put
this some time on the clock
but at the stroke of midnight
everything's gonna go back to the way it
was the The Carriage will become a
pumpkin
and all of a sudden you were this
glamorous princess but you're going back
to what you were just kind of a cute
girl who lives on the outskirts of the
castle with these demon sisters who hate
you that's what your life becomes at
midnight
and his midnight
was in that plane
in Moscow when he's sitting there he's
got his group around him he's like wait
a minute I now by the way how funny just
thinking of Putin and all the Kremlin
just watching this show they're just
sitting in the palace in St Petersburg
watching it and they all have
translators on and every now and then
Putin goes like this to the screen he
goes
but in the in in in in in in up in the
air he's sitting there and the bomb goes
off
and there's a minute where he goes what
was that and then there's a second where
he knows exactly what happened
and he's got all his people right
because you got to remember he's on the
flight he's flying high he's got all his
guys he goes oh my god look nothing's
changed I'm still this guy in fact I'm
bigger than ever
I'm on the era store he was on the era's
tour
with his people in the Jet and then the
minute that bomb went off
and the and the wing of the plane was no
longer visible and he started you only
get a second because then the g-forces
got you to the point where it's just
like it's over but the split second he
knew what it was when the Clock Struck
midnight
and the and the and the you know the the
uh the uh Carriage became a
pumpkin or in his case the jet became a
missile hurling to the ground he
remembered
what he really is and not Taylor Swift
you're not on the errors tour
you're in Russia
and that's the way it happens from
someone who's not Russian but who is
spiritually Russian I explained that to
you good night everyone I wish you well
as always bye bye